I'm meeting Richard Kaufman who's the
Czar in charge of New York's energy
hi I'm Cecily I'm Richard nice to meet
you Leslie so we're at jet row it's a
restaurant supply store it's one of the
largest solar powered buildings in New
York this is all solar yes the whole
roof is filled with solar panels there's
solar panels that are on the roof
provide between thirty and forty percent
about total usage we probably sell
somewhere between fifteen and sixteen
thousand SKUs everything from fresh fish
and produce to canned goods and
equipment if you live in New York and
you drive on the Bruckner Expressway you
can't help but see the giant roof with
the solar panels the state under
Governor Cuomo we have a support program
and the idea the support program is to
provide enough support until the
industry can stand on its own
yeah and under New York Sun in many
parts of state by 2020 the solar
industry will require no further public
support it's nice to see that she has
this passion for renewable energy I
think she was surprised by the the scope
of the project itself how large it was
and how much of a benefit that was posed
financially on the savings and on the
betterment of the community by taking so
much power off of the grid the challenge
is that you have hundred years of
culture and business models that's
changing how do you change minds what
does it take to get these people at the
top to make that change once we can show
that this is something that works we
would expect that other states will
support this because this is a example
of policy that is pro innovation
promotes economic growth and it's
cleaner
you